say you go to the Past lives Pavilion
and you find out that you were someone
in history that makes you so psyched who
would you have been who was heroic
Lincoln would be nice yes that'd be
great great choice did a lot of great
things for the world
and he was a lot skinnier than me
I'll go with Lincoln who would you be by
the way oh that's the one I asked you
that no I hadn't thought of it I think
about it right now Joe I Know Who You
Who
first words that come to Lizzie Borden
who is that Lizzie Borden Lizzy Borden
was like a famed killer fine and she
killed people with an ax hello Lizzy no
uh uh who would you pick for real I feel
like I would have to be someone with a
sense of humor oh okay you could be
Gilda she was great sweet like you be
killed that yeah and her and cheating
wife exactly maybe we're kind of like
Gene and gel that would be pretty good